et on poursuit notre série consacrée aux
pratiques agricoles économes en eau
depuis un arrêté préfectoral du 9 juin
dernier l'Indre-et-Loire est passé en
alerte renforcée voire en crise selon
les zones géographiques en cause la
chaleur et le manque de pluie mauvaise
nouvelle pour les récoltes alors des
producteurs de fruits se sont adaptés en
privilégiant les variétés et les plus
résistantes à la sécheresse comme les
abricotiers reportages auprès d'un
arboriculteur de 50 ans sur un droit
avec Léa Turquie
[Musique]
celle là par exemple ça s'est brûlé ça
en fait des dégâts mineurs mais
révélateur le soleil fait rage sur
l'exploitation de Mathieu une sécheresse
pas toujours évident à gérer les plus
touchés ce sont les fraisiers ça fait 10
jours que nous sommes à peu près à pas
loin de 30 degrés on constate des
brûlures sur fruits
bon maintenant c'est pas des quantités
qui sont
astronomiques mais c'est une table quand
même mais alors comment s'adapter à ces
pics de température Mathieu mise sur des
paillages naturels ou synthétiques selon
les besoins pour conserver l'humidité
accompagner donc de manières fumier de
vaches de telle manière à ce que les
arbres existent beaucoup mieux à la
sécheresse c'est de la chose c'est pour
limiter le maladies et aussi les
brûlures autre ajustement le choix des
fruits cultivés ceux qui s'en sortent le
mieux face à la chaleur ce sont les
abricots au départ sa culture nécessite
un arrosage régulier et ensuite presque
aucune goutte d'eau son seul point
faible c'est le gel l'abricotier une
fois qu'il a passé cette ce problème de
gel de printemps après c'est entre
guillemets presque du que du bonheur il
a une résistance à la sécheresse et à la
chaleur qui est très impressionnante une
fois adulte il est capable d'emmener une
colte malgré une grose canicule sans
irrigation des solutions alternatives
face à la hausse continuelle du mercure
l'été 2022 est un record de chaleur en
Indre-et-Loire cette année météo France
prévoit une période estivale plus chaude
que les normales de saison